that's weird my pants shrank
miles we'll give you that becoming
spider-man is a weird process but what's
even more weird
or maybe shocking is a better word is
how many huge celebs are the voices
behind the heroes and villains in the
film did you hear any familiar voices
when you watched the movie
okay then uh i'll see you around
jamik moore had his work cut out for him
when it came to bringing miles morales
to life
not only was he taking on a character
that has a huge comic book following but
he was also bringing a version of
spider-man to the screen that we'd never
seen before
he really channeled that teen angst
despite being 10 years older than miles
in real life
and there's no other spider-man like
miles morales want to be even more
impressed
this was one of shamik's first big time
movies and he
absolutely nailed it i love you
if you want more of shamiq you can watch
him in the netflix film let it snow and
he's also filming for into the spider
verse too
you know peter parker but do you know
peter b parker
into the spider verse gets a little
confusing with its different multiverses
which also means different peter parkers
this could literally not get any weirder
jake johnson well his voice gave us a
version of peter parker that isn't the
young
agile and hope-filled spider-man we're
used to but that doesn't mean he didn't
do
an amazing job he brought peter b
parker's wit
and determination to life and it's
really no surprise considering he was
one of the stars of the hit comedy
series
new girl who else could have been a
better choice to voice the sweet gwen
stacy than the pitch perfect star
herself
we knew as soon as we heard her belt out
flashlight in pitch perfect 2 that she'd
be going places
haley might look quite a bit different
from her spider-verse character
her white blonde hair is a dead giveaway
but her voice was
on point i'm from another dimension
i mean another another dimension from
the regular day-to-day teenager to the
spider woman we definitely deserve to
see more of
haley brought it all to gwen whether
he's playing nicholas devereaux in the
princess diaries 2 or james kirk
in star trek there's no denying he
lights up the screen
after watching into the spider verse the
same thing can honestly be said for his
voice
he voices peter parker yes there's
another one
perfectly the physical similarities
between the two characters aren't too
similar but he got peter
parker's attitude down packed i know
you're trying to do
and it won't work marishala ali didn't
just voice uncle aaron
aaron had more than one persona
including the threatening villain
prowler that marshalla had to embody
through his voice
i'll find him
you know me sir i don't ever quit the
versatility he had throughout the film
was phenomenal
if you think marshalla looks just a
little too familiar you probably
recognize him from his time in the
hunger games films as
boggs he was also in the epic movie
hidden figures
and the series house of cards lily
tomlin is a voice acting veteran
and you're not alone if aunt may's voice
brought up some 90s nostalgic childhood
memories you just couldn't place
follow me lily tomlin as aunt may sounds
so familiar because she's actually the
voice behind miss frizzle from the magic
school bus
are you mind blown yet not to mention
she's been featured in shows like grace
and frankie desperate housewives and the
pink panther film
let's all admit it miles becoming the
second spider-man
and the entire into the spider-verse
film would not have happened without the
character rio morales
that's why he's tough on you you know
that right a lot of the time
heroes are all about their family and
rio was the best family miles had
now the voice behind rio actually
belongs to actress
luna lauren
if you've wondered where you've seen her
before she starred in the first purge
and has been on shows like how to get
away with murder and ugly betty
her name alone is iconic but this
actress has proved herself
10 times over to be someone other than
just lenny kravitz's daughter
and her voice acting for mary jane is
just the cherry on top
she may look nothing like her animated
character but her voice brought life
into mary
jane oh don't be sorry it's just bread
if you want to check out some of her
other work she starred in fantastic
beasts
divergent x-men and is even dabbling in
the world of dc
with her upcoming role in the batman
stan lee
the man the legend the creator of
spider-man himself
how couldn't he have a role in into the
spider-verse although
short the creators made sure to honor
stan with a short cameo
he voices a shop owner named stan who
sells miles morales his spider-man suit
i'm going to miss him talk about a scene
being symbolic we don't know about you
but we never really thought we'd be
seeing a pig version of spider-man
ever my name is peter porker
but spider-ham made his appearance in
into the spider-verse
and he's voiced by the perfect celeb
john mullaney
his humor and unique voice acting made
spider-ham a true star
john's comedy experience and time on
saturday night live
definitely prepped him perfectly for the
role what does orange is the new black
and spider-man
into the spider-verse have in common
kamiko glenn
she played brook soso on the jail series
and also voiced the unstoppable penny
parker
hello
[Music]
she's yet another version of spider-man
and brought her own power to the screen
after into the spider-verse kimiko kept
up her voice acting in shows like duck
tales and summer camp island we're used
to seeing nicolas cage playing his usual
fatherly and adventurous character
but he mixed it up for his voice and
spider-man into the spider-verse
he voiced spider-man noir is that all
you got you're gonna fight you're just
pumping gums yeah hard-boiled turtle
slapper yes
another version of spider-man that comes
from the time of the great depression
wondering where you've seen nicolas cage
before you probably know him as ghost
rider
blink and you'll miss this quick cameo
but yup
post malone made a voice roll appearance
in the film and it wasn't just his music
of course his music specifically his
song sunflower was featured heavily and
into the spider-verse but he also voiced
a brooklyn bystander as added commentary
during a dramatic spider-man mission
scene
yeah i think it's a banksy jefferson
davis also known as miles morales dad
was voiced by actor brian tyree
why aren't you at school whoa whoa
if you've watched child's play boardwalk
empire and this is us
you've probably spotted brian a few
times before hearing him as jefferson
catherine hahn might be the voice
actress that looks the most like her
animated character
my enemies call me doc besides the whole
evil scientist vibe of course
if you're looking for more of
catherine's humor you can watch her in
bad moms
and parks and recreation ray donovan
x-men
origins spider-man into the spider-verse
they all have
one thing in common they feature actor
leave schreiber
in into the spider-verse leave voices
wilson fisk
one of the most notorious super villains
in the world of spider-man
you're not stopping this not today being
an
x-men this wasn't leaf's first rodeo in
the world of superheroes
no wonder he killed this role despite
natalie morales and her last name
she's not related to the one and only
miles morales
instead she voices miss caleros she
doesn't have a huge roll and into the
spider verse but she does play miles as
teacher
and pulls off all the teacher vibes
perfectly you're late again
remember how we mentioned leave
schreiber got to play villain wilson
fisk
well he didn't work alone he had help
from his evil minion scorpion who's
voiced by actor joaquin cozio
what justice said i need that marvin
crondon jones iii
also played an evil villain sidekick
named tombstone
marvin brought his past work experience
to really give the character his final
touches when it came to developing his
voice
you messed up big time kids very sloppy
then we have edwin h bravo he definitely
didn't have the biggest role in the film
but his scenes as a security guard for
brooklyn visions
really brought the comedic relief the
audience needed in the film
he's got a nice voice edwin has been
featured in comedy shows like shameless
and silicon valley
with a cast roster like spider-man into
the spider-verse it's no wonder the
movie got the amazing reviews it did and
with a sequel just around the corner we
can't wait to find out what other actors
they have in store for us
do you think post malone will make
another appearance which voice actor
were you the most shocked by
let us know in the comment section below
don't forget to give this video a thumbs
up and hit that subscribe button
we'll see you next time thanks for
watching